i hope so i mean i had a great interview
with colin quinn and he just had a book
come out and he was talking about how
we live in such crazy times that the
extremes
are telling the independents that
they're crazy
and he's he was saying you know this is
the majority of
people how crazy is it that people he's
like they're the craziest they're the
ideologue
it's locals week here on the reuben
report and i'm doing a series of mini
interviews with creators on why they
decided to become less reliant on big
tech and instead own their content
community
and livelihood with locals.com joining
me today
is comedian and host of the dumpster
fire bridgette fantasy welcome back to
the reuben report
thank you for having me always a
pleasure it's nice to see you again
before we get into your country your
locals community and you were
literally the first person that i got on
locals besides me
um i thought i thought we'd talk a
little bit about why
i thought you'd be the right person and
it's because you are trying
sort of like i'm trying i think to bring
a little civility back to discourse
how's that going for you it's going well
in the community
i mean and it is the last date
we did a live chat which was really fun
because that's like
the best feature ever that brings
everybody back to kind of the
chat room vibe which is amazing and
everybody loved
it and we did and you know i had some
biden supporters some completely
independent
some people who just aren't voting
people who were pro-trump
all of us were in the chat everybody was
laughing nobody and
nobody was fighting it was very civil
people were having disagreements but
still
being cordial to one another it was
amazing so
i believe that it's still out there is
it weird that you have to sort of
cultivate a space for that like i think
what intrinsically comes to people like
me and you
pretty obviously pretty simply naturally
that
these days it's just like gone
yeah i think it's i feel like it's less
gone in real life
than it is online so i think if you got
a group of people together
they probably would even if they
fell all across the political spectrum i
would hope they would manage to be civil
and i imagine they would be more soulful
than perhaps they would be online
although
everybody being quarantined and being
online
i feel like some of that decorum has
eroded in that time
and people are forgetting how to behave
online
and off completely and they're becoming
more and more kind of
polarized or entrenched in their own
beliefs so
it seems like things because of the
pandemic it kind of accelerated this
already
um rude and nasty
tone that we were already seeing amongst
people but i do think
you know online it's worse obviously
people are much
they're we are anonymous it's yeah you
know
i really encourage people in the
community to use their name to use their
picture
to so that we can get to know each other
and help each other and have it feel
more like a neighborhood and less like
uh social media where everybody's just
you know outwitting each other and
trying to be the snarkiest
yeah one of the things that you you push
a lot that i always appreciate is that
it's not
all about politics like even if you love
politics even if you live politics and i
love politics and
what i've been doing for a long time but
that that life is just not
about only that yeah i
i hate politics
and falling into this space has made me
hate them even more
and it's only affirmed everything that i
believed
before i knew anything about politics
which is that
they're dirty and they bring out um kind
of the worst in people and
it's it's it's not my favorite topic and
my community is very
you know i'm i'm sober so i
i try to talk a lot about just what i've
learned in coping tools
i feel grateful to have learned it in
sobriety you don't have to be sober
to have access to a lot of this stuff
and my whole
you know podcast watkins welcome is
about grit and resilience
and so i do my best to that
psychological
cultivation of that attitude is really
the most important thing to me
and i think in the community that's the
vibe of everybody
supporting each other i have workouts
with the girls five days a week so we do
zoom workouts
and it's been amazing i mean this
community has truly saved me
throughout quarantine and in the
pandemic just keeping me on the beam
and working out and working on ourself
and sharing goals and i've seen people
help each other through death
i've seen people healthy help each other
through health struggles
it's just been really inspiring to see
you know this virtual community support
each other the way that
community should yeah well it's funny to
me because
you're right like we all got sort of
jammed
online even more because of covid we
knew there was like a problem with the
online discourse
and then the the solution somehow is
that we're all online even more and
doing everything there and it's like we
need those spaces i'm having dinners
with people in the community
and and i've we've hired several people
for reuben report and for locals that
have come out of the community and all
that
um one of the things that i think you're
trying to do also is is carve out a
space
for people to still be to build still be
centrist
do you do you think the centrist thing
can survive the uh
the crazy partisan times that we live in
i i hope so i mean i had a great
interview with colin quinn
and he just had a book come out and he
was talking about how
we live in such crazy times that the
extremes are telling the independents
that they're crazy and he was saying you
know
this is the majority of people how crazy
is it that people
he's like they're the crazies they're
the ideologues they're the ones who are
extreme and will die on whatever hill
and carry
you know whatever water they need to
carry to justify whatever they need to
justify to themselves and
i think people in the middle you know
more than anything
i just want people to be okay with
expressing confusion
or expressing doubt or expressing
uncertainty or expressing
the i don't know that's a perfectly
acceptable answer
and these times it is crazy out there
and so wait a minute wait a minute are
you saying you don't know how much
yellow cake uranium are at the iran
centrifuges
no i know nothing they even put yellow
uranium in centrifuges that just sounds
like something
i i know less than nothing the more i've
entered into this realm i the more i've
realized i know
so very little about anything and
it's easy to just get online and become
an expert in
whatever is trending because that's you
can wikipedia things and become this
kind of
armchair expert in any single thing that
pops up but really we don't know that
much
unless we are experts and i i'm okay
with being kind of
the the dummy
who is asking a lot of questions and
that's the other thing i'm noticing is
that people are afraid to even ask
questions
it's not even vote for xyz if you don't
say
if if you say i'm not voting or i'm
voting
third party you will basically be called
a fascist
as well you're a facilitator fascinating
it's fast it's fascinating to me to just
see how
um that there's
a loss of people being able to speak
their
free and honest opinion and truth
and so more important than anything is
that
we all continue to cultivate spaces
where that's okay
where people feel like they can just say
i mean i can't tell you how many emails
i get from people who are politically
home
homeless who are like i don't even care
if you read this that just felt so good
to say
because they they don't have anywhere
they can express us so i'm hoping that
my community can be that place where
people can
um express their confusion i think jack
kerouac had a great quote i have nothing
to offer the world but my confusion
i feel like that's very much my vibe
yeah yeah well when i've jumped into
your community and i just kind of see
what's going on it's like people are
sharing other things besides politics
and they're
you know trying to help each other out
and it's like
that really remember a lot of foodies
the word social is in social media it's
like it was supposed to make right
foodies and and what do you have for
dinner and all that that's i mean
half of my community is just doing
recipes and dinners
but it's like even had your voice you're
smiling as you're saying it because it's
like oh
there's something good happening there
but it's it's like people are on twitter
just telling you how miserable they are
all day long and yet we're there too so
yeah irony whatever yeah i mean i like
twitter
because i really feel like it's the
thunderdome
so you get to just it it's
it's very hard to be free there too and
i like to challenge myself
on twitter because it's an exercise in
what i'm not saying
so when it first started when i first
went on twitter and started getting
noticed even by people on the right
you'll lean into what's working and i
generally have this rule where wherever
i have a tweet that goes
really big i'll do the opposite or i'll
say something just so that i can weed
out
anybody who might think that i'm too
much of a
you know you can see one tweet and be
like oh i know who this person is but
i i need to weed out the people who who
can't handle
differing opinions because on both sides
there are people who cannot handle you
saying
anything bad about trump or anything bad
about the left
yeah where do you see the internet going
in the next couple years you think that
you think these these big things that
they'll
they'll exist still it seems like
everything's kind of crumbling maybe
they'll look very different i've been
asking
everybody this question yeah that's a
good question
question um
i don't know where anything will be in
two years or three and
in the future i i feel like it
all of the things that we never could
have considered possible
are playing out or happening so i have
to really
really get my mind around being
comfortable with being
uncertain and not really having any idea
what
i think twitter will survive my my
feeling even seeing
that my 12 year old nephew now loves
twitter because it is
the fastest social media in terms of the
conversation that it is
this think tank for all of these kind of
thought
people um and the conversation is kind
of happening there i i wouldn't be
surprised if
it survives but it it
seems it seems like
the forces to silence people
and i'm seeing this even like i was in
clubhouse last night
holy crap i mean wow
wow i don't even know really i got an
invite a long time ago
i logged on once and i was like i don't
need to like listen to these people
talking i don't know like we need more
of this like a zoo
it's a zoo it's amazing it's you know
what i really love about it is that it's
basically like being at a conference
and you can just go pop in and listen to
a panel of speakers that's how i
see it but then with the introduction of
people that
make people in there not feel safe
it's caused a lot of discussion the same
discussions that happen on every single
platform about who's allowed to be
speaking who's allowed to be where and
so this is the
this is the conversation that i think
will alter all of these platforms the
most you know twitter
facebook who's allowed to speak where
and why i love locals is because i feel
like on malice and i have talked about
this at least we'll get a phone call
before we get booted i mean you can do
whatever you want it's up to you as long
as you're not breaking the laws of the
united states you know you've shown a
little
a little more skin than say i've shown
on mine but uh
i don't care what you do in there i mean
the whole the whole you know development
team they don't care it's your community
it's like we're just giving you some
tools you go
you go do what you want
yeah it's great it feels very free and i
like that and i
and you know it's really empowering in
that
i i have it goes through
um like my stripe account i feel like
that's
the most empowering thing because i've
been on a lot of these
other sites and it goes to them we get
paid out
we have to wait it's this is truly
giving the creators the tools to their
audience and
access to their audience and not being a
gatekeeper because
in in this time when there are
gatekeepers everywhere and you can just
get booted off a platform and sorry you
now have to fight for your stuff and
fight for your audience and now
scramble to tell everybody this feels a
lot more
empowering and i think that that is the
future
and it's the it's the most exciting
one of the most exciting things other
than just the sexiness of the actual
design and platform about
locals for me as a creator yeah just to
be clear for people that don't get what
you're saying it's
your stripe account meaning if you're a
creator on there it's your personal
stripe account so we
locals doesn't collect the money on your
behalf and then pay you you're paid as
people sign up right then locals gets
their cut but it all goes through you
so there's no there's no they're
subscribing and yeah
exactly and in my case they're
subscribing to fantasy inc i mean this
is
this is an amazing and people just kind
of assume
that that's the way it was was because
um that's the way it is and the fact
that locals has
made that very small but obvious shift
in the way that this
works is i think um
enormously important for creators in the
space moving forward when things are
shifting and and people are being
de-platformed and silenced
and and booted fetishy you're making me
look good for picking you first
i'm a business owner all right well
everyone can go to fetish.locals.com or
justfetise.com just redirects to locals
and i hope to see you in real life one
of these days my friend
i know digital thing
no i know it's it's overdue all right
we'll set it up but thank you for
creating this and thank you to the team
you have an amazing team behind you and
working with you and they're all very
loving and supportive and and brilliant
and talented
so i i appreciate all their help and i
want them to know that i
see how hard they work and what they're
doing and it's
it's not it doesn't go unnoticed with me
or my community i hear about it all the
time from them so thank you
awesome well i love to hear that and
they'll be happy to hear that all right
bridget we'll talk soon
all right thank you if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the non-stop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell